review is establish something called the
National Security protective agency with
more funding which is where our
intelligence services and other arms of
government are going to work with many
more businesses to help them prepare for
the risks that China and other countries
pose to them and to the country so you
know that's what the message to business
would be and the last thing I'd say is
look on the other side you know we're
open up new markets for businesses to
trade in in one of the great brexit
benefits is the fact that we're in
control of our trade policy and I was
very pleased that we were able to be the
first European nation to exceed to the
cptpp trade partnership
that's where the vocal Global growth is
coming from over the next couple of
decades you know that was a great bit of
diplomacy statecraft delivering a real
benefit for people at home in that
context though don't we need something
like an industrial policy and the whole
day next to the bank of England
suggested that today
well I think that means different things
to different people now if that's you
know if that if that means we should
just be focusing on who can subsidize
Industries the most then my answer is no
right and we discussed that uh in the G7
and actually you'll see in the G7
communique the very specific language
acknowledging that you know subsidy
races that essentially just shift
capacity between allies in at some kind
of zero-sum competition are not
appropriate and we shouldn't be doing
things at the expense of each other
that's not improving our collective
security but does if industrial strategy
means we should have a smart set of
economic policies to support the growth
of our Highest Potential sectors then
absolutely and we do and the chancellor
has spoken a lot about some of the
growth priorities for him we'll be
talking about life sciences just this
week we've talked about our digital
Industries Financial technology creative
Industries clean energy Advanced
Manufacturing you know those those are
our kind of Blockbuster high growth
industries where we have World leading
positions and it's in all of those we
have a clear strategy and it but it's
not just about subsidies it's about
smart regulation it's about skills and
so I think in those big growth areas we
do have very clear plans and as I say on
each of those the chancellor is holding
a particular day to talk about it and
we'll be doing Life Sciences this week
how do you evaluate the the threat or
the risk from the IRA the inflation
reduction acts in the in the US which is
essentially Mass industrial subsidy are
you confident UK's got the right
approach yeah I think like on this we
should feel collectively very proud when
it comes to this topic of climate change
who has the best record of reducing
carbon emissions in the G7 it's the UK
right by a margin and and we've done
that at the same time as growing our
economy so if you look since the 1990
Baseline we've reduced carbon emissions
almost 50 percent we've grown the
economy almost two-thirds that is a
better record than anyone else so we
should feel good about our approach it's
worked and if others are catching up if
others are Keen to focus on climate
change as well that's good I I welcome
it but as I said and we discussed this
specifically at the G7 and you'll you
see it in the communique
policies that descend into protectionism
at expensive allies zero-sum competition
that just harms each other isn't the
right approach but as you'll see what
I've just said has been agreed by our
partner countries as well now let's move
to Ukraine you've seen a lot of
President zielinski recently what are
the prospects this during for success
you know my first reflection is because
people talk about this counter-offensive
and it's probably worth us bearing in
mind that you know what Ukraine's been
doing for the past year is a
counter-offensive and over a year ago
they were invaded and they've actually
recaptured a large chunk of the
territory that was initially seized from
them and so that's the first thing we
should we should acknowledge and pay
tribute to them because many people are
including maybe a couple in the room and
you know were of the view that that
probably wouldn't be possible and this
would all be over in three weeks and
Russia would just run through it and so
we should take a moment to pay tribute
to them for that and then in particular
this winter not only have they held all
the ground withstood aerial bombardment
of their people and their civilian
infrastructure through a hard winter
um they've also managed to re rebuild
their energy grid and prepare for this
counter-offensive right so that's just
to get to this point is incredible and
their bravery their result is something
we we can all admire and be inspired by
and then I think they have every chance
of success because we've worked hard
with them to develop a plan that we
think can make a difference and then we
led the charge on making sure that they
had the resources and the capabilities
to deliver that plan you know we we were
the first country to provide main battle
tanks we were the first country to
provide longer range weapons you know
we've helped with their defense and and
those type of capabilities are what they
need for this to be successful as well
as training many of their soldiers
including those in tanks and Marines so
you know I think we've played a leading
role we should be proud of that others
have have done their bit as well
particularly the US and I think you know
they're in a very strong position but
the fact that we're in this position in
and of itself is something that we
should take a moment to recognize yeah
the ukrainians have done the most
extraordinary job but what's the level
of patience do you think across Europe
and in the US if for example the spring
offensive is not as successful as people
hope so I mean that was one of the most
powerful things of the summit the site
of President zielinski standing shoulder
to shoulder with the G7 I think it sent
a pretty strong message that we are
united behind Ukraine we're going to be
steadfast in our support and that
support is not going away just new
announcements over the weekend about
f-16s from the Americans there's their
longer range weapons from us just
recently
um so I think that it's pretty clear
that we're United and you can see that
from the messages coming out of
Hiroshima
um that you know your Ukraine can count
on its G7 allies and in particular the
UK to continue supporting them yeah I
mean it's almost as though it's prompted
a realignment hasn't it
extraordinary last year in in
geopolitics how do you see it do you see
it as the world assembling into blocks
you know the democracies against the
autocrats potentially oral
is there another explanation some people
say it's multi-polar how do you see the
world so I think one of the Striking
things is this is G7 obviously in Japan
in the Pacific and I I actually paid
particular tribute to the leadership of
prime minister kashida and Japanese
people
Australia is in the same boat but what
we've seen with the Ukraine conflict is
that everyone has realized that security
is indivisible between the Euro Atlantic
theater and the Pacific so you've seen
all these Pacific Nations whether it's
Australia whether it's Japan doing their
bit to support the effort why it's
because what are we ultimately fighting
for we're fighting for the rules-based
order and we're fighting for values that
are Universal democracy Freedom the rule
of law we all cherish those things and
so whether you're in the Pacific whether
you're in Europe people have recognized
that those are values that are worth
fighting for even if it's not on your
um doorstep and I think that's been
quite a striking feature of it and uh
and very welcome actually and what's
your message to Putin and Russia in that
context it's important we're not going
away
and we are now leading the conversation
with allies about what longer term
multilateral and bilateral security
agreements
we can put in place with Ukraine to
provide them not just with support for
the summer not just with support last
year or next year but long-term support
that they can count on and there's lots
of different ways and forms that that
can take but we are leading and shaping
that conversation you know why is that
important well way I think we owe it to
Ukraine but also I think Russia part of
Russia's strategy is to just wait this
out right
what was it over in three weeks we're
still there a year later but they will
be thinking well maybe we can just wait
this out as you said earlier people
might Tire Western democracies they get
bored they'll move on so part of putting
these things in place now and making it
clear to Russia that that support will
be coming to Ukraine for years to come I
mean it's not only will can ukrainians
have confidence in their ability to
defend themselves into the future it
also serves I think as a as a deterrent
and a message to Russia that the waiting
it out strategy is is not going to work
and actually that you know the the right
and only course of action for them to do
is to withdraw and stop the conflict and
how do you assess the threat to the rest
of Europe what happened in Ukraine and
it's still happening has prompted uh
enormous change with Sweden
potentially about to join NATO Finland
having having joined NATO
European security is now you know back
on the agenda I mean that was one of the
great miscalculations that Putin made
that far from fragmenting
the Allies it has strengthened them I
mean he's ended up with Sweden and
Finland on a part of NATO membership
he's ended up with an alliance that
stretches as I said across geographies
140 countries in the UN condemning
Russia's actions virtually isolated on
the global stage and then in a more hard
dead a hard a hard-edged
slant on it defense spending is going up
everywhere including in the UK including
in all our European partner countries so
you know what Putin has done is catalyze
a bunch of things that he probably
thought would not happen and would
prefer not to happen they are happening
as a result of his actions and that that
is good for European security you know
these are you know what what's happening
in Germany what's happened in Japan
these are big changes Sweden Finland
right these are huge changes to the
security architecture that we were used
to living in and indeed
resources being deployed towards it that
that is a good and very welcome step
given the the world in which we're
living yeah well let's let's touch on
defense spending you mentioned it there
the government refreshed the uh
integrated review recently
has the UK really got the balance right
on geopolitics
Europe and the indo-pacific and defense
spending is the mix
really right
that's that's a big question so on the
defense spending I think the answer is
yes so so we've always been one of the
largest Spenders in NATO on defense
spending largest in Europe one of the
few minuscule number who have
continuously met our two percent of GDP
Target
we spend more than 20 other NATO
countries combined
and then it's not just about the money
even though the money is increasing and
we're rising up to 2.25 over the next
few years with an ambition to get to 2.5
as soon as the economic and fiscal
circumstances allow Chancellor recently
put five billion pounds more into the
both the nuclear Enterprise and
rebuilding our stockpiles on top of the
record-breaking settlement that I gave
the mod when I was Chancellor so that
the money's there then the next question
to ask well is it being spent on the
right things do we have the capabilities
that
Terror and the answer is we do right
we're one of two NATO countries that has
the ability to deploy fifth generation
aircraft from sea right we have a
nuclear deterrent we have an offensive
cyber capability
you know I could go I could go on do you
have a do you have a fear on the the
Army which has shrunk a lot and may
shrink again yeah
yeah you know we actually the Army will
have a total Force capacity of a hundred
thousand split between uh regular and
and reserves now the defense secretary
is currently in the process of reviewing
that and there'll be a Defense command
paper which will be issued uh shortly
which we'll talk through all that but
ultimately my job is not to second guess
the decision that our military Chiefs
are making what I can say and what we've
delivered as a government is is record
defense uplifts and a trajectory of
increasing defense expenditure and
everyone should feel very good about
that in absolute terms and relative to
all our allies how that is best spent to
deal with the threats that we Face
ultimately is a is a question that our
military Chiefs will make and as I said
I've ran through a bunch of capabilities
um that we need to have and I know that
you can put orcas in that mix as well
with a offensive submarines it's an
aircraft carriers and a carrier strike
group etc etc
um
that's a decision that they will make
and optimize our forces appropriately
for that I think it might eventually
have to go quite a bit higher actually
if if two percent was
deemed okay when history was presumed to
have ended after the end of the end of
history I mean two and a half two and a
half three or four percent in Poland's
case actually this this year
are we not as democracy is getting more
into that sort of level of spending
being required well again I just go back
to what I said we're one of the
minuscule number of people that actually
spent two percent over the
virtually you know
we have when we're spending more than
two percent already so we're up to 2.25
on an increasing trajectory to two and a
half percent as as the fiscal and
economic conditions allow and you know
because I think that's
reflective of the threat environment
having changed as you said right would
face a more volatile and uncertain world
we can see that it's right that we're
investing to protect ourselves but as I
said it's not just about the quantum
it's about how we're deploying it and
again whether it's with the army
you know we have a there's a plan called
Future Soldier which talks about a more
lethal more agile more Deployable Armed
Forces as well as just the Quantum of
them right and that is a relatively new
way of thinking about it which is
important but I'm I'm just gonna Alex I
know on time but you talked about the
balance between that and the
the diplomacy side which I think is an
important an interesting question
and it I think in the environment we're
facing it it actually is incumbent on us
to what we described in the integrated
review is to out cooperate and out
compete our adversaries and actually
what we want to be able to do is shape
the international environment that we're
operating in and relationships matter
and that's why I think we have invested
very heavily in building diplomatic
relationships in all three theaters in
the Atlantic in Europe in in the
indo-pacific and you can see that just
this week the partnership that we've
signed with Japan means that the UK
Japanese relationship is the strongest
it's ever been particularly on defense
and security where the arrangements
we've got with them now we are the only
European country that they've ever done
that with in only the Third Country ever
beyond the US and Australia and we're
starting to have those conversations
with South Korea we joined cptpp we've
got orcas we've got the gcap program for
the next generation of fighter aircraft
with Japan and Italy and so and as you
can see whether it's the Windsor
framework and other things or deals with
the French and the albanians on illegal
migration you know we're diplomatically
operating in all theaters delivering
benefits for people at home a very quick
final question uh British economy about
Britain's place in the world British
economic performance in the last decade
has been I think it's fair to say
sub-optimal
um now that has consequences we've
talked about defense spending but given
that backdrop how do you respond to
those saying naming no names Simon
McDonald that Britain has a declining
role in the world
so I I'm going to gently push back on
the economic one first in the sense that
well if you look you know what's
happened since 2010 and actually new IMF
forecasts out today which are a big
upgrade in UK growth
um which has been systematically
underestimated for for many years you
know what is a record since 2010 right
well the record is we've grown just the
same as Germany faster than France Italy
and Japan and only behind the US and
Canada right that's the record
is that sub-optimal great of course of
course we always want more growth but
out of all the people after import
energy we're top of the pack we're
Germany so that's the record on growth
and during that time what else have we
done Chancellor had an excellent op-ed
recently which kind of went through some
of the greatest hits we've created
Europe's largest Life Sciences sector
yeah we've got one of the world's best
creative Industries we've you know clean
growth is we've got the second largest
install base of offshore wind we've got
strength in financial services that's
World leading and you know I could keep
going you know we created more unicorns
and digital investment in this country
than France and Germany combined right
so I that's the economic record and we
should actually feel very good about it
and when I was in Japan last week what
did we announce 18 billion pounds of new
investment into the UK from Japanese
companies enormous vote of confidence
um in our city just a few months ago PWC
did a survey of a thousand Global CEOs
uh more than value a few thousand from
100 different countries asking about
investment destination number one
European destination UK
third globally behind the US and China
right so that's the economic side of it
look on on these narratives and I
address this in Parliament yesterday and
if people can have a look at my
statement
you know what have we achieved in the
last six months right Windsor framework
new deal with the French in the summit
the likes of which we haven't seen for
years you deal with Albania to
strengthen our ability to deal with
illegal migration we've got cptpp first
European nation to exceed the gcap
program for the next generation of
fighter aircraft with Italy and Japan
we've got the Japanese defense deal that
we've just signed we've got
orcas incredible unprecedented defense
partnership with Australia and the us
we've got our leadership on China and
probably most importantly our leadership
on Ukraine not just with hard support
but also leading the conversation from
an intellectual perspective about the
right way to try and resolve this
conflict and make sure that Ukraine is
successful that's what we've just done
in the six months and I don't know how
you can look at any of that as I said
operating in the Atlantic in Europe
in the Pacific
delivering benefits for people at home
whether it's tackling illegal migration
creating jobs growing businesses how can
you look at any of that and say that
Britain is not anything other than
confident free and doing great stuff
that's making an enormous difference in
the world that's what I see when I look
at our foreign policy and having spent a
week with people from around the world I
think that's what they recognize too
like Britain is is absolutely delivering
not just internationally but
domestically we're a respected Ally and
we're doing something that I don't
believe any other country can do and the
best way to think about it is in the
space of about 10 days
I went from having the first
anglo-french summit we've had in New
Year's very successfully then going to
San Diego to sign August with two of our
five eyes Partners Australia and America
and then a week later we acceded to
cptpp as the first European nation to do
so right which other country could do
all those three things
all right I'll I'll leave that to you
but I think there you go I mean that's
that's the case on that on that
optimistic note uh prime minister thank
you for joining us at the London defense
conference the Prime Minister thanks
very much